[Music]
hi I'm Warren Simmons former director of
MIT Museum we're here today to talk
about the history of women and how that
history has developed over the years
particularly last 50 years MIT Williams
now the dean for undergraduate education
and student affairs and have been for
two years at MIT I have many deep
memories of MIT going back to the 50s as
a as a kid whose family was at MIT so
I'm both participating as an individual
with that background and also history
I'm Emily wick I came to MIT as a
graduate student in 1946 to study
organic chemistry and that was right
after World War Two and everybody all
the grad students everyone all the guys
could already believe they were still
alive but they were and it was a
wonderful time to be here
and also everyone remembered all the
wonderful things MIT had done during the
war you know it was the national
resource and everyone was proud to be
part of it
well I got my PhD and then postdoc
until 53 then I worked at Arthur D
little for four years and then I came
back to MIT this time in the food
technology department as a research
associate and in a couple years I was
appointed assistant professor and worked
like crazy because at that time there
was an age limit when you would become
no longer
legible to even be considered tenure and
I had about two years to go so but I
worked real hard and I was fortunate in
having some wonderful graduate students
who made it all possible and some
postdocs and so I got promoted and got
tenure
soon after I did that Kenneth Wadley who
was the Dean of Student Affairs at that
time wandered down to my lab and he said
you know there not many of you girls
around here on the faculty and there
were two of us myself and Margaret
Freeman in the Foreign Languages
Department and Ken Wadley knew that mrs.
mcCormick
at that time this was about six 1963 by
now the first part of McCormick Hall was
built and the number of women students
had increased considerably but Ken knew
that mrs. McCormick was going to give
money for a second wing of McCormick
Hall and there would be many more many
more significantly more women students
and so he said how about coming halftime
to the dean's office and being an
associate dean of student affairs with
primary responsibility for women's
students across the whole range of
student affairs so that's when I moved
up the dean's office and met dotty who
was already there understanding all the
students and the way that system worked
and how the departments worked and what
was going on well I'm Dorothy bow and I
came to MIT in 1950 to work in the
metallurgy department where I worked
with graduate students my professor
Norton was about to retire and so I knew
a lot of women's students mostly because
my office was on the main corridor and
lots of people dropped in to see me I
had always ran a very open office door
was always open and anybody could come
in dr. Compton always came in on his way
to lunch
say hello and how are things going today
which i always will remember had lovely
blue eyes anyway a lot of women's
students at the time were not doing well
academically and we're feeling that if
the environment was better that we might
that they might do better and become
part of the mainstream of the Institute
which at the time they felt that that
wasn't happening for them because mrs.
McCormick's money was becoming available
for a dormitory ken had decided that it
would be a good idea to have someone on
his staff who could oversee the
environment for students and their how
new housing and in fact women across
women's students across the board it and
at MIT and he went to talk to Polly
bunting at Radcliffe about this to get
some ideas and she suggested that he
hired Jacqueline Matt felt to come down
and do a complete research project from
a history and write a program for
student women's students at MIT and
which she did and they're her second
year at MIT I was asked to come down and
work with her because she was new to the
Institute and didn't know who to contact
about what and where to get different
bits of information which I was able to
do so I worked with her for I think
about a year and a half when she put
together this program which was a
wonderful really really hard working
person who put together an awful lot of
information and it caused a great deal
of discussion both pro and con but was
certainly an important document and
something that I think has laid the
groundwork for for what went on since
that time jackie was then offered a
position at Sarah Lawrence College and
left two to become I believe the Dean
there and that's when Emily was invited
to come down I wasn't sure Emily would
would want to keep me on because
I had I had I had done a lot of this
background work and I as I said some of
it was contraband controversial and I
figured someone new will want to bring
in their own their own staff and lay it
out and I knew she had background at MIT
so that what I was doing wasn't always
nice but anyway she did ask me to stay
it was the beginning I think of
absolutely remarkable relationship we we
work together as a team right what Emily
did very well I didn't do very well and
the other way around we got to know all
the students really every student we
really worked very hard to to identify
each person by name make sure that the
office was always open and that knows no
student felt no woman's student felt
that there was nowhere that they could
go if they needed even a simple question
answered we did administer housing
athletics just about every every
possible student issue came four women
came through our office in fact a lot of
men's students came to our office for
the same variety of issues but as time
went on and and Ken left that job I had
been there seven years and I decided it
was probably time for me to move on as
well which left Emily there and she left
shortly after that in that gap time we
felt something needed to be to be filled
in we needed to fill in for the time
that we that we were there and Milly had
come on board during that time as the
Abby Rockefeller Ma's a professor and we
were able to include her and many of the
things that we did and I will turn it
over to her from there
she took the ball she took the ball
well I actually came to MIT before this
time but I was at Lincoln lab starting
in June 1960 and I was many years before
we met at least seven and I came to
Lincoln lab because it was a absolutely
first class research lab and I had a
family problem because we there was
husband and wife it's two members of the
same family both in science and similar
fields in fact and I was a postdoc at
Cornell University where my husband gene
dresselhaus
was a faculty member but at that time
that 1960 there were nepotism rules and
so as long as I was a postdoc with my
own support it was fine for me to be
there but when the NSF postdoc
fellowship came to an end that was the
end of my appointment and there wasn't
even an opportunity to work for nothing
so ethica New York is sort of the end of
the world
there was no industry there was no other
thing there was that was just it and so
we were looking around for a place we
could both work and there were just two
places that were willing to take two
people in the same field and MIT was one
of them IBM Corporation was the other
one so we had the choice of individually
we could go to all kinds of places put
together we we had very limited choice
and we decided we didn't want to have a
traveling marriage so that's how we came
to Lincoln lab and not only that word
that they hire the two of us but they
encouraged us to interact strongly and
write papers together and all kinds of
things that were kind of against the
rules of that particular period in time
Lincoln lab was a wonderful place to
work I had a kind of a job there that
allowed me to do research
most anything I was interested in and
those kinds of jobs just don't exist
today so it's to young people it's
almost impossible to describe this
opportunity and it was a great
opportunity except for the fact that was
a female and as and as the number of
children that we had increased
conforming to the hours requirement that
that they had became more and more
impossible and the particular thing that
that led to my difficulties and coming
down to MIT campus was the rule that we
had to report for work at 8 o'clock in
the morning and as a number of children
increased this came more and more
difficult and I was always late and I
got awful lot of flack there were two of
us that were in this situation we seemed
to have our babies nine months phased
between us so there was always somebody
with a new baby between the two of us
the other person was Laura Roth who is a
brilliant solid-state theorist and she
was the one that got fed up with the
harassment first and she left for tufts
university take a faculty position there
and so with one of us gone the brunt of
the criticism fell on me and after a
while I got so that I couldn't take it
anymore also so I was looking for
something to do and at that time I
became aware of the a P rockefeller Mo's
a chair which had just been founded and
I was the I plied or somebody applied
for me of course I was I guess a more
accurate description and I was offered
this visiting position which I accepted
and turned into a permanent position
very shortly after I arrived so that's
how I came to MIT is a very circuitous
and different
path and it was several years later in
1973 when I became the permanent holder
of that chair which was a very very nice
chair because it gave me quite a bit of
resources and freedom but I at any rate
when I first arrived it's important to
mention this this chair because the
chair had one of the conditions about
the chair was a scholarship for women it
was for women scholars to promote female
scholarship or the scholarship of women
scientists and engineers so and in
reading the Scriptures on the subject it
became clear that I should find out
whether there were implications about in
a broader sense if I was supposed to do
something for the female students on
campus so at at that point very early on
I made contact with Emily I suppose
first and you you couldn't meet Emily at
that time without meeting dotty so they
were sort of like two twins so that's
how I got to know them both I each had a
plate of quite a different role in
implementing women's Act issues and
activities on campus and they made it
clear to me that not only even though
there were there was no stipulation
within the chair that I had to do any
particular thing on behalf of women they
certainly would welcome any help I could
offer because there was so much work to
be done and it was far beyond what they
could do and having a third person would
both make it fun and increase our
effectiveness by a factor of two
something like that they say would be a
multiplication factor by the additional
idea
that we could bring to bear and discuss
and and it really turned out that way I
think that that we energized each other
a great deal and Andy on days when
things when we could be discouraged we
found ways to be encouraged so our
relationship started in 1967 and was
very intense until Emily left and we
will recount to you some of the things
that happened during those years could
we go back and talk you mentioned Dottie
about the number of do you knew every
woman student by name and and so forth
what was the the women student
population that you could do this
service to there are about a hundred in
a class at that time if I remember right
or somewhere in that sounds very close
to a hundred in a class yeah number that
sticks in my mouth because I'm thinking
of a hundred in a class and with you
know with with the attrition and and it
sounds about right
so yes again our door was open and we
saw many graduate students the fact that
Emily had been a graduate student and
was a faculty member and had graduate
students of her own did did in if
they're in a department that cares about
graduate students and if their professor
runs a place where there's a home-like
atmosphere then they they've got a home
already and it wasn't until you didn't
want to do something on a more Institute
wide basis or where you needed a little
outside yeah I'm thinking in particular
the Emily Amelie had meetings and Cheney
room you know that was one of the first
things that we tried and the
it had a purpose that was partly to
educate me
the manure that is the local climate and
to meet with the students without
anybody else I just did it more or less
with it you came once in a while to
check up on me but this was a personal
exchange to educate me about what the
issues were
and to try to come to setting some
priorities about where to put our time
scheduled meetings or were they they
were and I guess that that the most of
the kinds of issues that came up were
that we had a group of students that was
clear that they were academically very
gifted but they had some difficulty
getting through the system and it wasn't
related to academics but was climate
related and they had each and every one
of them seemed had general concerns
about oh that they had low aspirations
they had confidence problems they felt
that the professors didn't pay attention
to their questions in class and it went
on and on in this way and these are
particularly gender related issues that
were brought up were almost entirely
gender related and and this was the only
way I could get into these issues
because the classes that I taught for
the most part were all male because my
department had essentially almost no
women had a very very small percentage
much smaller than the Institute as a
whole Electrical Engineering was kind of
behind some of the other departments in
attracting women although I think that
they made some effort they pointed me
and they pointed other faculty fairly
early on but that where the students had
to select the department that was it
took some time
so that group of students was both
graduate and undergraduate who came to
talk with you I think they really I mean
that was my we said them that's right
but Emily Emily knew a lot of students
and we encourage them to use Jani room
which she had used as a student it
wasn't a way video it was a place to get
away if things weren't going well and
then having Millie there was just an
attitude you know a plus because I think
this raises a point and I think we could
cover this early history early 40s 50s
history what was the living situation
for womens students as well when I came
was the second year that 120 Bay State
Road had been opened it was a nice house
over there and in Boston and I think the
capacity was 18 and half of us were grad
students in half undergrad and Margaret
Alvord whose husband had taught it Tufts
was the manager and she was a good good
friend mrs. Compton was very much
involved and mrs. sage in that house
mrs. McCormick there was a special fund
mrs. McCormick game that allowed to you
could hire a taxi in torrential rain day
mrs. Alford used to go to the Friday
afternoon boston symphony concerts would
mrs. McCormick and so we didn't see much
mrs. McCormick but we knew her presence
was there and of course she was the
class of 1904 and and she well I think
mrs. Alford mrs. Compton and the
Killians they were they knew mrs.
McCormick cared about women's students
but wasn't there a restriction on the
number of women's students based upon
the number of housing yes baby yeah I
don't know whether in the forties when
they really cared where you lived
that's why I think there were very many
women who came as undergrad
and then the other thing to set the
environment is that you know we talked
about how we tried to know every woman's
student and in today's context that
almost sounds like we were babying them
a lot of them true we were trying to
nourish this this little it's like a
little plant you know surrounded by this
big environment which everyone really
you know they love is not the right word
but you're stimulated by it's so
exciting just the learning the the
information that the one you know the
wonderful people walking around on the
campus that they've done all these
things in science and technology but but
it was just such a small group of women
and then the margaret cheney room I
remember when I was a grad student when
I first came I had gone to Mount Holyoke
and graduated in 1943 in the liberal
arts college and we had real good
science and you know we worked real hard
you come down mighty and I used to think
you get into the into the atmosphere and
you you become part of a group in your
department and then if you don't if the
system doesn't break into little bits
you're gonna succeed but but if a guy
bust you that's that's the sad part
and I could never have survived it as an
undergraduate I wasn't that
professionally driven I would have
probably done something else I probably
wouldn't be major them where they're
women or love me in the ER when you were
a graduate student particularly
inspirational to you that gave you the
force to go Kathryn Hazen Holyoke some
years before me
gotten her master's at MIT you know
there were these ladies around and they
paid attention these were Kathryn Hazen
was a good example of someone also we
called on oh yeah of course it was when
was Harold about the Institute and she
was not a shrinking violet she she
wouldn't know
Margaret Compton I mean with all that
college worcester and everything in the
Compton family she was a wonderful lady
right there to you know give a little
moral support or you know say well
that's not the right attitude when you
came as a graduate student the
department was a good gang of people and
I think a lot of it was that it was
right after World War two and there was
a special atmosphere around yeah it was
different how is it different well was
because you know the war was really a
terrible thing to be living through and
you well what's going on you'd go home
at night or you'd read the paper you
didn't know but what's your best friend
or your brother or your fiancee or
whoever you know they weren't alive
anymore it was and to have all that over
and to have Europe kind of the Marshall
Plan and things were you know beginning
to come back together in Europe and
around the world there was a time of
family relations oh yeah there's so much
to win absolutely we're so proud to be
here and particularly in my department
oh yeah is that there was a real launch
launch up between people yes radar and
I was born here yeah and people that
were in and radar so many of them went
to Los Alamos another right oh
absolutely I work on the Manhattan
Project right so forth so and then they
came back here so they had an inside
track yeah and a kind of deep wisdom and
seasoning I mean those people that came
in gave a seminar and taught the look on
that guy's face you know he'd lived
there was a group when I was in melody
Department for instance who never
thought they would ever attend a
university that's right these became you
know with the GI and super bright super
capable very committed but mature and
knowing what they wanted to do and I
think that was a very special group of
people that I think you're both
referring to but Emily we don't when we
think of the GI Bill were there other
women students and in your grad yes the
other women grad students at that time
weren't a lot of us but but I worked in
dr. cope scoop arthur country was head
of the department from a new year
a very distinguished chemist and a very
very fine nice absolute integrity I
learn more about nowadays I read in the
newspapers about you know people accused
scientists of fudging results this and
that dr. Koch made sure and it didn't
enter our heads that you would ever put
in your research notebook something that
you didn't observe I mean whether it was
a big blot of coffee but it was it was
wonderful training let's follow that a
little bit though because I think Ken
Wadley was one of those people
absolutely who was he came in who came
at that time in engineering through yes
came in 40 I believe in Ken was one of
those people who didn't expect to be at
a university like this and I can recall
one time when we were talking about what
his expectations were for women students
and he said I wanted to be a first-class
place for women students just as it is
for men and that's you know a goal that
you should keep in mind when you're
looking at any part of what you're what
he called across-the-board issues was
that we should be considering it as they
making it a first-class place he became
dean for student affairs 63 it was must
have been around six 59 or 60 years
because I went down there I think
engineering department and was a I think
he had won the bladder water one of the
awards for teaching whatever and had
come to dr. Stratton's attention in that
in that route and again dr. Stratton was
influential because he had three
daughters I think in and had and also
had at the contact with mrs. mcCormick
and all of this kind of came together at
the time I think mrs. Stratton I wanted
we talked a little bit about
her role and I one thing I remember
about her she was the first president's
wife whoever invited non-faculty
non-student women to participate in
anything and she had invited me and an
ALICE and a number of other people to
come to a discussion group of some kind
at the president's house where we talked
about about what it was like to be a
woman at MIT and I think that was that
was the first time in my time at the
Institute that anybody in that kind of a
position he had had had brought it up so
you think it was a conscious decision on
somebody like Ken Waddell a Dorje
Stratton's part two didn't just start
increase the number to make it more it
was my impression that they were after
increase of numbers rather than increase
in the quality quality of life for the
students that were there I believe even
when when I came and that was a few
years after the time we're talking about
here we didn't have expectations of
large numbers and I remember once doing
a back-of-the-envelope calculation
thinking that by the the time I would
retire we would be up to 20% a kind of
outer limit of attainability why why
would you even think if you think there
was a drive to increase to some degree
but within a limit I mean why was this
20% sort of well in our anecdotal
contacts with the women's students it
was just a question of interest I the
ones that we had basically gave us the
impression that it was pretty hard to
make make your way even as a student let
alone as a career and in the fields that
we feature here at the Institute so
that's that's one factor and then it was
felt that that women just weren't
interested so there was both the bias
and the reality of the
Coffee and making your way through this
place or any other like institution and
then establishing a career and there was
no history of it yeah the numbers in a
profession that was soso 60 the whole
curriculum at MIT has changed to be able
to speak of it in detail but there are
many more fields that are not just
strictly the straight-ahead engineering
and in pure science that back in the
when I was a grad student or even in the
60s was was the norm and the other thing
that's happened is is women are heading
for specific majors I mean Chemical
Engineering is now or has been over over
half right and of course biology is an
enormous amount of women and there's a
sort of biomedical combination or by an
engine on the others on the other hand
women have gone over critical mass and
every single day so it's not that that's
not really the whole story and in the
early work that we were involved with
let us say just around 1970 we made some
conscious efforts at that time we had a
I guess we'll get to this later our our
grant from the Carnegie Foundation yeah
I mean that would one of the of the main
points about that grant was to set some
priorities for women on campus and I
think that we put very strong emphasis
to get women in the mainstream of MIT
not out on the peripheries but have them
study the same thing that the men
because a very simple calculation would
show that that an institution has some
strengths and in various areas of
science and technology and and howdy you
should see that you see that in terms of
the faculty appointments and if the
women students would go one way and the
men's students would go in another way
that would limit how many
yeah that you could ever have and it
would be a very undesirable situation so
we orchestrated our grant in a way to
promote women's participation and in
fields where they hadn't been before
we'll talk about the number of women
students that were admitted was governed
by the number of dormitory that's a
critical thing that's all right boy
during the six because it meant that
that you filled the spaces that were
available for women there was a
residence room there's no one that
actually came in was it existing when
you moved to the dean's office yeah I
think so yes there was a there was a
residence rule for women students at
that time but that was first time so
prior to that time as a woman student
unless she lived with her family was
required to live on campus now at the
time there was no way there wasn't
enough space at all for the men's
students I mean they could never have
applied that rule to the men's students
but it was part of from the point of
view of improving the quality of life
yes yeah of the women's students but it
did put up a limiting limit on the
numbers and it did appear to be biased
and since then remember we had a group
of women students who got very very
upset with this and went to Kim loudly
to accuse Emily of being unfair to women
students by applying this rule or
including this rule and I've forgotten
now what that was resolved without too
much difficulty whatever but the student
body and the chair of apple butter de
Camry MIT I don't know if you remember
that
and we said we didn't get me Apple
bottom it made all the difference in the
world because smart young women who
might have been attracted by MIT my
living conditions were we're just crummy
and you didn't really have a chance at
athletics or or the whole range of so
why not and at the same time of course
the former men's colleges we're going
co-ed so they could go anywhere able
young women could and then about came
along that what the second part of
McCormack got built and that meant the
numbers just went right up this was
before any thought of affirmative action
thinking of you know goals and
timetables that's this is pre history
missions work at that point well I used
to read about two hundred and fifty
folders I'd read all the women's folders
and I'd read some men's to get
calibrated yeah so no well you know is
this all different and so we were always
part of the admissions but women's
submissions were handled separately as
well I think your report yeah I think so
and then we recommend it as as the dorms
here began to go co-ed student house
went co-ed and we could anticipate that
women would be infiltrating the
residence system as well as there'd be
McCormack for people who didn't want the
co-ed lab experience so so it was then
then the numbers could even grow more in
the outside world the whole culture was
changing so rapidly but what the report
established was equal criteria which was
very
important dish and then a corollary of
that if you have equal requirements why
not have the same admission process so
the same admission process I think
happened before nineteen nineteen
seventy I think about 68 or 69 something
around in there Emily's report has a
very significant information in it which
I think can be used
number of things and it indicates what
the quality of life we're women students
was before McCormick and after McCormick
academics went changed and went up the
whole participation and a variety of
Zaun campus things all all made this
dramatic change the minute you saw this
on campus support system so to statement
what a larger number of women the
numbers increased and and the whole
thing just takes on a very different
different view of what happens to
students when they were here the next
thing is though that Emily that really
then became involved with that original
report and there were some aspects about
that that were important the men many
men felt that the prospect the potential
of good students was quite limited and
that the numbers that we had would be
limited by the cutoff we had one cutoff
for men and another cut up for women
women I had much higher qualification
and it was felt that once that was
equalized that would be the number and
that was a very small number yeah in
actuality so at however what they didn't
take into account was that once it
became people became aware that we were
interested in having women students and
offering equal access and we were one of
the first few schools that had equal
access at the time that we did this the
numbers shut up far beyond any
expectations and not only that but the
quality of the applicants also went up
and this surprised the men greatly
surprised me too you remember the
committee at that time the admissions
committee oh yes I was working on that
for a few years a couple of years before
our report and that sort of lead I think
that that we were working together on
this led to courage to come up with this
report that was a different report yeah
that was a different way that that
report wasn't about the original
admissions report we did we did that one
1968 really was the first and the second
report with all these other people it
was 1970 yeah and and that started
because of the demise of your office
Emily yeah that's right that that's what
brought it about and and there were
there were two things that happen as a
result of the demise of your office that
happened very abruptly remember it was
one day it wasn't the next night wasn't
maybe you could explain what happened
about that that I needed to go back and
if I wanted to have any credibility as a
scientist I had to get back there and do
something then no sooner than I got back
to the department and now in Holyoke
came wondering if I would be interested
in being the dean of faculty and I I
never thought I'd ever leave MIT in fact
I told the the faculty member on the
search committee who called me and it
was an old friend of mine
it's about Timmy I mean I I live where I
want to live and I love it here don't
bother me well then I sat down again and
I thought and all my experience at MIT
and during the
the Vietnam troubles and the divestment
of the Draper lab because of my halftime
position is Dean got me invited to
meetings kind of across campus meetings
where you learn about what was going on
and how people like oh gosh Jerry
Wiesner and Paul Gray and all the people
who had the whole burden of the
Institute on we're dealing with this and
I had become very interested in in
educational institutions and how they
worked and I'd also become very much
interested in women's education so I
said to the search committee person I
called her back I said I don't want the
job but if you if you folks want to
waste your time I'd love to come out and
find out how much the candidate but then
when when I ended up being the candidate
and mr. David Truman was the president I
mean it was a challenge I was ready for
in a smaller institution on a scale that
you can encompass and also I like the
fact that you know there were classics
departments I still loved MIT but you
never know what's - I said to the search
committee for the Dean I'm really I'm
not interested but I want to tell you a
few things you serve raised something
which I was had been thinking of and
this is the the role of the whole
late 60s in this whole student the
student unrest as we I guess you you for
mystically comment today did that make
the role of
increasing women's students more easier
or did it I mean you think of so many
things that happened during a time your
op star
and an IEP a lot of things changed mi
t--'s outlook I think Ken started what
he called agenda days when students
could meet I think usually at lunchtime
in the Student Center and bring to his
agenda topics that he they felt needed
to be addressed or I need it to be
talked about her or he you know would
put an end to it right for her would she
had a way of doing but but many really
useful kinds of things came out of me up
for discussion with students with
faculty I think I think we have to to
say that students were much more active
as I've been at the Institute now for a
long time as a faculty member and that
was the one time when the students were
most interactive with everybody yes and
they felt that they were on an equal
basis with each and every one of us
including the president yes so it was
actually rather good time to make
changes but most of the changes on the
women's issues came about with the
demise of your office I think Emily I
really think that that because my career
certainly been very much like this and I
don't know about the rest of you but
adverse things always happen and but
adverse things often lead to
re-examination and through the
reexamination good things happen so I
would say that the Women's Forum and the
I ap activities and many of the things
that we did at that period were directly
connected with reexamination
we were told that that the way women's
affairs were handled at MIT would be
different in the future than they had
been in the past well if they're
different and everybody's on an equal
basis so we should all get together and
talk about it so that's why we had that
study so that's this 1970 study and you
have a copy of that it's amazing that
you still have a copy of that that's
history yes is a difference
somebody has it around Dottie used to be
our archivist during those years she
took to all the records and
implementation she was the only
organized person at least I wasn't
organized in this area I had enough to
do keeping my research stuff going
conscious effort to show us a mainstream
women's issues I think the fact that I
decided I should go back and do science
kind of led to people thinking about
well what should be done next it was a
change of Dean's yeah that generated
that that review so also we had become
really overburdened with the pre medical
advice was doing pre medicine it was
wonderful to know all those wonderful
young folks but it really that was the
time when when the boomed for going into
medical school it was just burgeoning in
the Harvard MIT program was beginning it
was beginning and so we just had more
than we could handle and women started
getting interested in medicine yes
before that time they were very few yes
so it was big thing but after Emily's
stepped down because I'll give you my
side of that story I don't know if it's
your side when you step down that was a
conscious decision that you made but the
question was what what next what should
happen next and the students had one
opinion they thought things were going
just beautifully the way they had been
going they didn't want to see a change
okay maybe Emily had enough of this but
there'd be somebody else taking Emily's
place and the new Dean Neihart his idea
was that we wouldn't have another person
with the same duties as Emily he made
that known to us and so I I was the
recipient of many unhappy women students
and and Dottie was probably the
recipient of many more than I that I had
but we thought we should have a some
kind of strategy meeting and the second
thing that we thought we should do is to
try to have some alternate methodology
to give support to women that felt that
they needed additional support and the
first year of ia P just happened
coincidentally at exactly the same time
as your office disappeared it was
identical yes and it was even sort of
plus or minus a month yeah it was so it
was amazingly a coincidental what
happened so we put out an ad in that
first bulletin for ia P that we would
have kind of a workshop activity during
that very first I ap as a kind of a
support group for women it was supposed
to be students and so we advertised this
in the I ap bulletin I Emily has a copy
of the advertisements and its notes
taken at Women's Forum meetings Wow
[Laughter]
we didn't expect anybody would come yeah
and the Cheney room at least 75 and
maybe up to a hundred well the place it
you couldn't admit another person it was
standing room and it was incredibly
crowded they couldn't get in through the
doors and because we made a mistake that
we didn't put students we just put women
and what's that what that told us yeah
that was a great mistake that we made
that was a mistake for my team best
mistake it had great repercussions
because we got the message that we
needed as women faculty we had to take
the leadership for women at MIT not only
women's students and that was a very
important observation that we had missed
up to that point yes because that there
was nobody else that's listened to there
is nobody else has listened to as a
faculty I don't think you and I had gone
separately to other women faculty we
wouldn't have had the success first
place we didn't probably know them the
other women faculty particularly well
when you were all in this room with all
these women
it just was clear well we we had a
pretty good inkling about the women
faculty because I remember that that
from the period that I came until you
you finished your term of office we used
to meet over in Ashdown house for lunch
and we had one table and we would talk
about priorities for women at MIT I
remember those very well I don't
remember
well you had a zillion meetings and I
had because your mistake wasn't quite a
mistake just before that first floor
meeting it was advertised in the IEP
bulletin and a contingent of women
employees came into the office talked to
you and talked to me and said can we
come to this
we're finding things that MIT not as
good as they should be for employees as
well as maybe students and can we just
come and listen we won't be disruptive
we'll just and that's I think and I said
yes sure well you thought it would be
five people I thought gee you know I
thought they'd be five or ten students
there and it turned out to be in fact
some on the building five cara de we're
the ones who had said you know look
there's some issues that we'd like to
raise and we think if we talk with other
women it may be helpful both for us and
for other women to see that see what's
going on so they passed the word and I
think that that's that's how so many
women showed up you can blame that blame
that on me
but it really does it was a remarkable
mean very exciting continued because I I
got the message of what I had missed all
this time and what was necessary and you
know we have to also point out that
Jerry Wiesner was very very supportive
of our activities they were they were
really behind us absolutely because I
remember I remember this and I often say
this in public actually so I might as
well own up to this because I know when
it happened
and it happened in connection it in
conjunction with the Women's Forum and
some proposals that that came after that
so that's January of 1970 isn't it I
think 72 well it's at that very first I
ap and I guess the the paper that we put
together the very first draft was not
quite up to Jerry standards and I might
owe to him but he took me aside
it and I gave me some counseling on how
to do a proposal and I never failed
after that and he was my first and
severus mentor on science policy because
that's what I call this whole thing oh
yeah it's a different part of my career
yeah and and what he said was you have
to treat science policy and service at
MIT and elsewhere the country on the
same in the same way you treat your own
research and you have to have a level of
excellence sensually and you have to to
think through what are the purposes and
and and to fashion any proposal and
document that you issue with the same
kind of excellence as expected of your
MIT scholarly work mm-hmm that was
terrific advice what a wonder wonderful
wonderful man she always came and took
notes well she was so always available
for staff work we used to do these
studies and she would take her part
along with all the other committee
members and called students individually
one-on-one and and we used to do
telephone quizzes no question here
that's right she was one of the I don't
know if you know that but she was one of
the members that that called the
students and she was one of the very
best people that we ever had in doing
those calls she was a terrific staff
exactly during this time from 71 to 73
was work work was being done on the
Women's Centennial I'm Warren Siemens
former director of the MIT Museum we're
here today to talk about the last 50
years of the women's history at MIT with
me is Roz Williams
Dean Dean of undergraduate education and
student affairs since 1995 I'd like to
pick up with the the women Centennial in
73 at that point this all these other
things were seem to be happening
simultaneously and working with the
amitié we put together an amazing
exhibit on the history of women up to
that point at the MIT we lined the
corridors in June 73 with stories of the
fascinating and phenomenal things that
had been done by women alumni and did
this were you aware of this from the
dean's office did this have any effect
in the overall thing I can remember the
students being very impressed with Leo
with the and coming into the office and
saying did we know certain students or
did we but I also remember the story
that some students were very impressed
with Florence Luscombe and they'd wanted
to locate her
so they went I'm not sure where they
started maybe the Alumni Office but
eventually found her living in central
square and I think a rooming house of
some commune and but they were
determined that they wanted to invite
her to have dinner with him and talk
with her because they thought she had
done some such interesting things so
they asked a young man at the desk or at
the front if if philosoph Arendt's
Luscombe lived there and he said yes and
he hauled it up the stairs
hey Flossie this some girls talk with
you and she was about 90 years old I
think 1909 right and she came down the
stairs on the double and went to went
and visited with these students and had
a marvelous time and in fact stayed
connected to them for quite a long time
but I I think the other thing that came
out in that display particularly is not
just these pictures then but it made
almost a personality out of many of
these people that you depicted there and
I think too that mrs. McCormick comes
as really exceptional woman I think the
fact that she that she encouraged the
the birth control research and that she
was so active in the suffragette
movement I mean after all two things
that are important to women were today
were those being able to vote and being
able to have some control over their
over their lives and I think that really
left an impression so whatever from my
perspective at the time that students
came in to talk to me about those were
two people that I think were shown in
that and that particular exhibit and
they came to life for the for the
students there's one actually actually
two portraits one in in McCormick Hall
but there's a wonderful one over and
like all the prisons axillary office
Catherine wilmore's office you go from
the prison's office directly across
Catherines place and I think what I
wanted to really is to show the
enthusiasm that our students had for
getting to know students who'd been here
before them and had gone through many of
the things perhaps if they've gone
through and that it really was they were
searching for for stories and
information about these people it was an
easy way to capsulize the history of
women here and a very effective way that
was just the time I was leaving to go up
to Mount Holyoke so it was kind of just
wound up there sort of mixed message
then if your office was closing down and
this is perceived as a crisis at the
very time that you're celebrating the
centennial it sounds like a very
christ has turned all into good things
but you don't know it at the time of the
crisis well at one point we should make
about mrs. mcCormick that's really
important I think for women at MIT it is
often said that admitting women is a
negative for fundraising because women
don't have the resources and they're not
as good donors as as alumni now I heard
that a lot in the 60s oh well before we
had too many women at MIT one of the
arguments against admitting more women
was it was going to do some something
terrible too hard was very detrimental
to fundraising but the truth of the
matter is that of the Alumni up to that
point Kathryn McCormick gave more money
than anybody else still today I wonder
what what were some of the other
arguments against increasing the number
of women students at MIT because now in
1997 it looks like sort of inevitability
right this is the way history was of
course marching but I doubt if it
something that way in the sixties I take
that one huh I think it was a question
of of capacity to to do the work at the
time that I came in we had a bimodal
distribution we had women's students
that were truly superb and then we had
another bunch that were not not below
average okay let's call it that and on
the basis of the admissions process
there was no reason that they should be
below average because they were admitted
with high capabilities and I would say
certainly people in my department and
you know we're sort of mainstream MIT
disbelief that women could do the work
here they felt that as high school
students when things weren't all that
competitive women were studious and they
were motivated and so forth diligent
they would be fine but put them in the
in a college environment and all
demands of the MIT undergraduate program
that they didn't have it to make it here
and so the demonstration was and we had
women around for a hundred years and
they were substandard based on their the
admissions criteria so we have to lower
the admissions criteria to it to get
more women right I mean that was the
whole thing and then they would flunk
out of this place so that I I believe
that the fundraising was only part of it
the other part was there was disbelief
that they couldn't make it here and I
think that what on my side of it was
that that we didn't give that we didn't
have an experiment Irene this is after
you left 1974 you weren't here anymore
and I was asked to write a paper for the
I Triple E education journal and well
they asked me write a paper what to
write a paper about I didn't really know
anything about but there was anything
particular about educating women in
engineering so on I came up with a
prediction of that critical mass what
was critical mass and why was important
and so the premise was that women today
weren't doing so well in engineering
because they were below critical mass
and they didn't have the same
educational opportunities even though
they were admitted to a university they
would be singled out they'd sitting in a
seat around them were a whole bunch of
holes you remember how that was and we
were teaching they had one girl in the
class and there was just no other
students next door it's like poison she
tried to ask a question it wasn't taken
seriously we heard that time and time
again from the women students that that
to participate in class was difficult
and it was difficult because the
professor didn't take take them
seriously and because the their
colleagues the cohorts the same age the
other
students.they it was barrier and women
didn't want to seem stupid so they
didn't want to ask a question that might
seem stupid and you can't learn science
if you won't ask a question that was on
your mind it doesn't matter if it seems
stupid or is not really the most
important questions often do seem stupid
would you define that critical mass
yes well at that time my formula for
evaluating critical mass was I took the
size of a class which is about 20
students I don't know if that's the
right number of a 15 to 20 students and
I've figured that you need more than one
woman student in the class that if there
was zero or one then she wouldn't
participate in the activities on an
equal basis and it was it wasn't before
there were two in the class that that
there was a chance that she would ask a
question so I used that as the critical
mass and you work that out simple
statistics that gives you 15% and what I
have had the pleasure of watching over
the years and as the various departments
increased their numbers of women's
students and the numbers got up to 15%
there was a change in the performance
and when we got close to 15% the bimodal
distribution that we were so used to
when when you were in the dean's office
disappeared and and the distribution
became similar to the distribution of
all the students but of course at the
time that I came up with this
supposition we didn't know and this this
work is actually often quoted in and
education of women students let alone
engineers this critical mass thing we
have a wonderful photo of 26100 when I
was just because I became the primary
physics lecture hall with two women
students wonderful miss Sheila would
know in this sitting in this mass of
well sort of but I mean so they were all
professor forced them all forward so
they're not
circle around them but at least there
were two white shirts rest them all have
coats and ties well I I know my own
teaching here in the early years until
maybe 1975 or maybe even beyond that I
used to see this circle and empty seats
around the women students I saw that
myself oh look at I'm sure there
probably is in this happen there are two
two areas that might respond to that
question though discussions that I
remember sitting in on Emily never went
to a meeting without being absolutely so
well prepared that uh that there was no
no no no you had to be because you just
never knew what kind of question was
going to come up so it was always well
prepared and when she presented this
report that we just talked about on
admission policy to the I think it was
faculty council the room was very
crowded and I was sitting in the back
row and I had taken along a woman's
student with me just for a support and
because I thought she'd be interested
but I dragged her along anyway there to
questions came up and one of them was if
we had met all these women's student and
they're successful and and they graduate
from here what will they do when they
leave and you said what do the men
students do and a dead silence fell in
the room because nobody knows what the
med students do either so I thought
there was only way to answer their
question I mean we had a lot of data to
indicate what the women's students do
but our numbers were small and even
though we said you know of the hundred
in the last class you know 80 went to
graduate school and so forth it wasn't
it wasn't really what they were looking
for and so we but I thought that was a
you know question and answer that needed
to be said because I don't think anyone
really knows you know we're all our male
students end up and whether they end up
using the education that they had and
the other question that came up was of
this class size and displacement if we
admit hundred more women students will
we have to will we have to reduce the
number of me
students in that and that discussion
there's no answer to it and you have to
look and I think in fact the disk of the
discussion went on for several years I
think finally they did increase the size
of the class size to but but slowly and
modestly yes the increase in the women
numbers of women is small at first yes
yes so that it didn't disturb the
balance but look what's happened yes
it's not a small perturbation anymore no
but I think it probably was a good
decision the way it was done I mean to
do it in that incremental way so that
you weren't it was it was the only way
to go because we didn't know ourselves
what would happen no no in all fairness
that's right I'm sure the question and
the first question was aren't this
aren't the female students going to get
married it's right they were looking
it's worse than that there were very few
career opportunities at that time for
science and engineering it was bad
enough in universities but to get a good
position was a lot more difficult but I
think that what we could do if we want
to know how well they did is to look
back what our graduates have done yes
and that is the most amazing story and
we know about the big successes because
they're prominent in the newspapers and
they're national leaders and they're our
students and so many of them yes and the
other thing is that when you go to a
professional society and you look at the
women's speakers yes that they have and
the people that are asking intelligent
questions and I look back and I remember
this was in the class of this race in
the classroom and the percentage of
people that are making their mark that
are our former students is large yes so
you know that tells us that we did
something right yeah and I would like to
mention one other data point yes
recently we're starting a campaign to
raise funds for a new building C s
building computer science building and
so we go back and look at
our alumni and of course alumni includes
women nowadays and how many women CEOs
and have a vice presidents of this and
that the number is staggering I had no
idea that we had so many of our women's
students as entrepreneurs and running
their own businesses and this and that
we could never have predicted not at
there I'm just backing up what Millie
just said
next year is the hundred and
twenty-fifth anniversary we got ellos we
should look at some of those statistics
it I you you wouldn't believe what you
see but it's part of that we asked the
Alumni Association that the Technology
Day committee asked the Alumni
Association to pull out a list of all
women CEOs and those with a profit
professor or proper professor in their
title it's a volume that thing I mean
it's a staggering number of people that
are and this is only those two
categories so I mean it's it's it's it
was just very just totally unbelievable
because it sort of it's happened in a
sense very gradually and yet obviously
it's very much a surprise to us sure if
you go back to those pivotal years and
they clearly is a hinge there I mean
something yeah I mean you've just
enumerated a lot of reasons why many
people students alumni faculty might not
have wanted to see MIT significantly
increase the number of women so who were
the people who wanted to see this happen
or the allies that you've said you
didn't feel isolated or alone or
particularly embattled so who you know
how how are you helped by people in the
MIT administration or faculty or well I
always felt that the whoever was the
president and from Jillian and Stratton
through they we and all the upper
administration they held you to to high
standards and and severe questions but I
never felt that in principle they were
against this happening it was a matter
of excellence quality you know doing it
right
I think we were carrying a banner yeah
to do it and but I never felt that we
were shut off from know we always were
allowed to you know you owe as I said
you were always invited I think that
that facts were strongly on our side yes
because the admissions take that
particular case we were admitting men
and women by different standards mm-hmm
and our faculty thought that was
repugnant yeah we should have it the
same standards so they were on our side
you know it made it easy who was the
director of the head of the Committee on
admissions from the aro department it's
I'm terrible names today but I know he
called me one day and said I'd like to
try a social experiment and see how the
women how we could admit more women and
just kind of see how that would work and
so he asked me for some data and and he
was really the a chair at the time yeah
yeah I know who you mean and I forget
his name any still on the faculty yes
and if I go through the aero-astro list
I can easily identify important to me
but he really was he had this open kind
of he had heard some facts he wanted to
get some more and he considered this to
be a very as I said social experiment
that he wanted an engineering experiment
almost he set it up that way and I think
was one of those as you asked about
allies I think I always consider it
wasn't if he was more proactive on our
parts they were there a number of people
that were proactive and well the other
thing about the MIT faculty is that you
know with so many I don't mean to slam
the humanities and if you can bring up
what conclusion do you come to they look
at data and we we were very careful
about our reports yes our reports have
some statistics lots of data yeah we
were fortunate that you - you know what
a scientist was an engineer same
language and they spoke the same
language is the man that's right there
was not a whole lot of social kind of
stuff yeah you know there was never a
whole lot of bit how many homes came in
for counseling and how many came in for
you know this problem or that was
education it was always educationally
based yeah i think it's proper to point
out these two trailblazers here we have
Emily who is the first person who sort
of came up through the ranks to gain
tenure at at the MIT yeah and the first
person to be appointed professor in the
in school entire School of Engineering
you remember actually Sheila wouldn't
all preceded me but I got tenure before
she did that's right so if she came
through the ranks I think that says a
lot in the sense that these were then
the people who pushed the whole ball
further and opened the door we were part
of the the whole cult yeah gotta be like
the place and enjoyed the environment
we're stimulated by all the intellectual
activity I always thought that was a
great thing but that's what it took any
lesser people a pious group would not
have been able we did the same thing
with the women that that we did with the
guys we academic excellence and
leadership mm-hmm I think these are the
two things that we emphasized and I
think I'd say we did rather well I think
we got leadership in our women which was
very difficult for me to do academic
excellence was relatively easy because
they were expecting that when they came
here but leadership is not something
they were expecting to do when they came
here but they left with it one way or
another I think we could mention a few
of those people we talked earlier about
not during one of these sessions about
Maria Kissel
Scottie Margaret MacVicar be nice to get
some recollections of the most I think
of pall of stone civil engineering and
you know when she lived in senior house
and she would I would go over and eat
lunch with her and in her and her room
well that was co-ed living and I got to
see you know colored living in that's
right right but you know received her
PhD and went on to just matter of fact I
think outstanding a lot of resource and
I think from in Washington I believe she
is now I have a Christmas card from her
now and then but Margaret MacVicar of
course who started out being quite
social and sailing and doing all the fun
things and then sort of said you know
hey there's a lot more here to be done
and just went ahead and did it it's
going a little bit of her career I think
that's interesting because of her long
term however shortened career here yeah
well as I said she started out being you
know active and sailing and doing all
the things that at first year women's
students were doing at the time and then
all of a sudden it the whole world
opened up for her this was a place where
she could be Margaret MacVicar and not
play a role that I think she was
concerned about when she first came so
she did I mean she just got into her
academics and she got into opening up
connections where Europe is a good
example where she felt that there was
just so much to be learned if he could
connect up with a lab and work there and
be part of what was going on she was
president of the dormitory when it first
opened when McCormack first opened and I
remember her coming into the office and
asking me to read her her acceptance
speech from mrs. McCormick which was it
was hard to believe that uh you know
that a student had written this it was
just so right to the point how important
it was
for the women students to have this
dormitory how much it meant to them and
then of course she went on to to do
graduate working on to Cambridge I
always remember her she to show what
kind of a person she was she told me the
story about going to Cambridge and how
when she came back she told me the story
that well she was there
you remember Margaret kind of swung
along and went anywhere she wanted to
and did most anything she really wanted
to learn about but she walked across the
lawn at Cambridge along which people
were not supposed to walk across at
least students weren't supposed to walk
across and she didn't know that so she
went she was called to her what her
tutors office to explain why she walked
across this particular part of the green
and the so she said well she had to get
from one place to the other I mean that
was the shortest way and that's the way
she went and she was told that that was
not but the way to go and that students
weren't allowed to do that so she
decided that um she should call students
together and stop this nonsense where
you could walk on the Cambridge campus
however I have a feeling that it was not
successful when she left Cambridge
students who are still not allowed to
walk across that lawn but it was very
typical of the way Margaret if there was
something that that was she didn't see
any purpose for doing then it ought to
be challenged and and she did that she
was a product of the late 60s and
Vietnam era and everything and students
were just questioning Authority she was
part of that and that was one of her
great strength that's right absolutely
absolutely
you know she was class of 65
yeah but that was after she came right I
know yeah no amazingly short amazing
that's right she had something to do she
said about doing it is very methodical
and organized well she marched into Paul
Gray's office when Paul was in the
dean's office yes that I want to do this
but she had it all laid out and and you
know when I was in his office Paul Gray
was the Dean for the freshman class so
he was all part of the the the the Dean
of Students team yeah Margaret was
totally fearless yes yes and she was
appreciated much more so in later life
and much more so on the outside than the
inside it took a long time before the
MIT community appreciated that's right
and the people that were closest to her
in her department gave her the most
trouble yes and they had their
expectations of an academic was research
and and teaching and and Margaret was a
leader that was her focus walter
rosenblith was really very fond of
Margaret and in fact understood but but
he was another visionary that's right
cut out of the same cloth he understood
her and he you know could see what she
was trying to accomplish so but her
colleagues that were close to her had
much more difficulty in seeing the big
picture found her yeah she's a real
bridge figure because there are
certainly people in the dean's office
today who worked with her closely and
revere her and you know she really kind
of connects that era with really with
him present well she's the one that that
did you're up not only at MIT but the
whole country right yes this is where it
all started and
and we're thankful that is starting up
here because it really it's always
worked the best here and we have a few
competitors here and there but but it
didn't matter where Margaret's office
was or or any of the what she called
trivial things the point was to get to
the goal that she had set to accomplish
and none of these other things where
were important and I've often admired
her for being able to do that if she
just cut away all the things that didn't
need to be that's right it's right yes
yes that's right exactly exactly
but I'm trying to we had we've had many
other outstanding we talked about truly
Jackson another one who he would have
known in those early days must been
fascinating to meet that person as a
undergraduate here yeah I guess you know
her that's better than I did as an
undergraduate graduate she took a few
courses with me so I I had the pleasure
of teaching her and I think you had much
more social interaction with her during
her undergraduate of the office was it
was sort of on path natural pathway from
McCormick to wherever you were going you
just came in the side you know building
it's just down the hall everyone I was
sick
yeah 506 so they could just duck in the
you know the naval architecture open
doorway where the anchors are and talk
that was a perfect location it was and I
you know there were times when you'd see
someone go by with their head down
clearly unhappy and you could you could
run out and walk the rest of the way
with them and and surely graduate world
she Margaret were about the same
whatever you that was in the same well I
guess Margaret might have been a year or
two I had of her yeah I think she was
about the same time as Aviva pressure
yes yes and they were great friends no
vote
physics mm-hmm they were good supportive
for each other
mm-hmm where the women stand so that
would be about 19 when I first came they
both took classes from me and I think
Aviva was still an undergraduate she
must have been about a senior and she
was taking graduate courses and she was
terrific yeah and a lot of leadership
yes mm-hmm
I don't know whether we could say you
know it surely came in to celebrate when
she really passed she really kept some
big exam I don't know whether it was
physics or math but she came in to
celebrate
[Laughter]
there were times for instance when a
faculty member would call and said I
have a woman student who can't take an
exam tension is too great in this room
with all the being just permanent maybe
was the only woman student in the class
usually that was I had one like that and
I would say if with your permission can
she take the exam in my office and so
that often happened we had a little
office it wasn't used much or maybe some
days Emily wasn't going to be in the
office should be in the department and I
would say with your permission she can
take the exam here and that often
happened student would faculty member
would bring the fact that that and I'd
Proctor it so to speak
they'd sit in the in the inner office
and take the examine and there were I
think times when that helped I think
female student who was every words that
the men who didn't want to who were the
source of the tension or the or the
woman's student I don't quite understand
where the yeah I'm not sure I think I
think it was at the time the student
might have just been feeling the
pressure
yeah yeah I don't think that the women's
students do a lot of support for each
other yeah very tremendous that was
unbelievable and they still do I know
that hasn't changes if a nerd
yeah Shirley Jackson was unusual case
because she was the oldest or the most
senior I think of the black students
here in physics are close to the most
senior and she organized the younger
ones unto her and she did the mentoring
and the tutoring and she got a whole
cadre a whole generation of black
students through they wouldn't have
passed without her and they look up to
her like almost like a demigod I she has
a real special place in our history oh
she definitely nuclear regulatory
commission I know jeepers there's some
honest people and they were in safer
hands and also knowing both sides of it
the technical side of yeah and the
people's side there aren't too many
people that can do that yeah when Vera
Castillo coughs key was on the faculty
and she had gone to Mount Holyoke she
was a class behind me and when we were
undergrads her father would come to
visit he was good friends with the
faculty at Mount Holyoke and and that
was all the time when Los Alamos and and
all that was going on and when he died I
felt the world was not quit was another
person that you felt tremendous trust
integrity yeah yeah did Sheila play an
important role here and oh they are
they're opening up admissions or were
the women faculty here she wasn't so
much into the admissions thing she came
her her contributions were many others
but it wasn't so much admissions the
athletics program was one area that we
owe a tremendous amount to her equal
opportunities overall was something that
she did a lot line and in the early days
she was our Institute problem solver
when there was something that with
faculty issue this is not women's issue
but just across the board a human issue
and I think some of that experience came
from the work that she did with the
women students
she was really outstanding now the fact
is that we don't know about each other's
contributions so well because after you
left Emily the two of us Sheila and I
divided many of the responsibilities and
this is a we did this purposely so that
if she was doing something I wouldn't do
it I had total confidence that she would
do a tremendous job so and likewise if I
did something she didn't do it and so
therefore I don't know as well but one
thing that we did do that I I there were
two things that we did that I think is
important for the history one of them
has to do with our Carnegie grant and
the other one is is the faculty tenure
review and I think you wanted to hear
about both of these and they're somewhat
connected so Dottie worked very hard on
the on the Carnegie project and so I'm
sure you can contribute much where I
left off where I leave off but in 1973
all of a sudden we got a bunch of money
to and it was there was some ground
rules about what we were supposed to use
this money for and maybe Dottie couldn't
tell you better than I can
supposed to be used for but when we had
the money we decided that we would use
it for things that would have some
impact so we did a sort of most
everything against the rules but we saw
well I remembered that that the rules
basically was that faculty would take
some that pay some of their salary and
we would do some kind of scholarly
studies and for most of us we decided
that it was most important for us to be
in the classroom for most of the
students that I ever taught I was the
only female faculty they would ever see
ever see and it keep me out of the
classroom was the worst thing that
Carnegie could ever do for MIT so and
this was true of the others so we just
did our own thing and we didn't pay very
much attention and hopefully the
Carnegie I'm not sure exactly about the
report but we maybe should go back to
David Hamburg and who's still around
would appreciate the effect of this
grant on MIT because it really had a lot
of things so some of the things I worked
on was we set up a a course a subject
what is engineering and the I should I
want to give you the bottom line of that
at the time we started this was 1973
approximately women were in selected
fields but they were not in the
engineering school by and large very
very few and they weren't doing too well
and we thought that we should use
resources that we had to get a better
distribution of women through the
different departments at MIT so we set
up this course and we thought we would
have like about 10 or 15 students and we
would work on heath kits and you know
get them more comfortable with
engineering things when they were a
freshman so that they would be
comfortable and going on to the
sophomore etc courses because freshman
is sort of a common
curriculum so this was kind of what the
idea was so in the freshman year we set
this course and I did a one semester and
she led to the other we alternated and
we did us about three years and first
time was offered we had about 10 or 12
students is which is the next second
semester we had a hundred and it went up
from there and we had a huge fraction of
the women students and even huge a
fraction of the minority students just
about all the minority students would
take this course and so they would have
as role models as Sheila myself when we
were doing we do some some of the
classes and then we got all the great
people at MIT who would come in and give
us guest lectures dr. a / and Edgerton
and you know all that all the great
people they would tell us about their
career and oh those those are just
marvelous stories and this had a big
impact in the enrollments because the
people that came they decided all of a
sudden that they could do it too that
was that was the message of the course
that if you were admitted to MIT you
could get a degree in almost any
department certainly there were many
options for you in the engineering
school so so that led to many very good
careers another thing that we set up
from that was a faculty group faculty
luncheon group it probably had a name
but I can't remember exactly what the
name was
and we met approximately once a month
talking about issues for women students
graduate students faculty et cetera and
we provided lunch so that was what the
grant provided I'm not sure that that
was supposed to be but it was it was
important in getting our women to be in
keeping the attendance up and then once
once the usefulness of these meetings
was established the attendance was quite
good and one of the activities we had
had to do with how to get tenure at him
and what we discovered from from these
monthly meetings is that the women
faculty got almost no information from
their colleagues about what it took to
get tenure in their departments and that
most of the people in the departments
were obviously men and they didn't feel
all that comfortable in discussing these
kinds of issues with women so if they
weren't doing so well they wouldn't be
told and then pretty soon that tenure
clock came around and they wouldn't make
it so we thought of ways to improve the
information the fact sharing information
sherry and we developed a technique of
we had a sort of mutton Jeff type show
and we took sheila widnall x' resume and
she was the can we we did a little play
and she was the candidate that came up
for tenure
every time we ran this program and and I
was the department head and I would I
had been a department head that time so
I knew what what the the issues were and
Sheila had received tenure so so we knew
that this is a proven case so then we
went through the the resume and we kept
the resume at the time she got tenure so
we could look to see what counted and we
went through each of these things
publications grand students teaching etc
letters of recommendation we went
through all the different things and how
one prepares one's career to have a
better shot at tenure and also the
message that if you did the right things
to get tenure at MIT you were doing the
right things for your career that these
were one in the same thing and we had
sessions on how to get grant proposals
through and all of these kinds of useful
where did they start approximately
Carnegie's 1973 and we did them for 10
years yes we did for 10 years because I
all the years through the time I was
ahead of the material Center I was
chairing this and staffing and you know
in the beginning you staffed it and did
the the work together the whole thing
because there was a lot of staff work
that was necessary notices send out and
reserving rooms and reserving meals and
all this sort of nonsense to you how
many were there in that sort of
tenure-track saying in 73 well it was
the numbers increased a great deal
around 1970 in the early years because
we Stern had the idea he had he was
original proponent of affirmative action
before it was ever recognizer had a name
or a concept or anything I'm talking
about Jerry Wiesner he had it up in here
and and he decided that women we he said
that the women faculty that we had had a
very large impact on the place and he
said that we needed more of you that you
people who were just totally overloaded
you've heard him say that sure you
remember that still and he said that we
needed more people to help him to
improve the quality of life of all the
students because he thought we had it
contributed not only to the women
students but to all the students so
there was a sort of a on hid a hidden
campaign and about 1974 there was some
kind of committee that was appointed to
would try to improve the recruitment of
women faculty I don't know how well it
worked
but whatever means the number increased
but the mentoring was terrible in the in
those years so our faculty group
mentored that was with it we were a
support group basically and we were
across the whole Institute and obviously
that requirements and the engineering
school a little bit different than
humanities I
I won't argue that but there was some
irreducible principles and and the
process is mainly the same there's an
MIT process that we explain all of that
on your luncheons when I first came to
MIT so I was in the early eighties and I
remember that quite well they were quite
well attended yes they were well
attended yes yeah well it had some
impact in increasing the probability of
tenure and toward the last few years
when I thought it was time that I could
bow out of this because it was quite a
bit of work the probability of women
getting tenure you know in proportion to
the number that we had in the pipeline
was equal to that of men and when that
happened I thought we were doing okay
you an opportunity to meet faculty and
other departments remember we used to
take on projects like looking at the
undergraduate curriculum and this and
that and and what the effect of
pass/fail was and we would talk about
Institute wide issues because we were a
small enough group that we could focus
on things and I I believe that was
appreciated by all the faculty know
there's the Carnegie grant we did a lot
of things with it and it was originally
as you said set up in a certain way and
we decided that was not the way that MIT
ought to do it and other schools that
received these grants as it's cool had
identified an office and hired a person
to sit there and to administer and we
decided that was probably not the thing
to do here that we should spread it
around and do some faculty some students
some a variety of kinds of things so we
did have some student interns who worked
on projects with women faculty which I
was also a wonderful way to get students
who were interested in physics for
instance worked with Vieira on a project
and I think Millie and Sheila's course
there are a variety of things that we
did with that with those funds which
spread them they reached my far more
people than they would have had we put
had we set up an office
and just a you know directed them in
some sort of administrative way but we
just sort of flew in directions and I
think all of them I think was a useful
well one of our protegees I'm not sure
if she was exactly in the original
Carnegie but she came a few years later
but I sometime in the 70s a lab at one
of the dorms at McCormick do you
remember that Dottie that was Denise
Denton and there was another young lady
I forgotten her name and Denise became a
very very young Dean of engineering at
the very large engineering school
University of Washington aged 36 you
imagine that and what she learned as an
undergraduate to begin with and then as
a graduate student was really quite
amazing because she was working with
students as an instructor when she was
still an undergraduate setting up this
lab course and they ran it themselves it
was very effective and then that a
training allowed her when she was a
graduate student to help out with some
teaching at one of the neighboring
colleges here so by the time she
graduated she had all this teaching
skill and documentation so it made it
easy for her to get a faculty position
and then she got tenure and then from
that went to the Steve's job we really
have an amazing group of another case
that that's a little bit like Margaret
MacVicar where people judged her just on
her engineering achievement but that
wasn't the whole person yeah the whole
person was all the things she's doing
that's why I brought up previously that
I wouldn't love to see some more of
those people here on the faculty it
would have been wonderful to be able to
keep more of than which you know we just
have a look on what we've kept quite a
few of them and I what I I'd like to say
I say it differently Dottie that as I go
around the country
you know I see them everywhere their
mission area and I believe that the
leadership that they brought with them
to their institutions was kind of unique
because they weren't used to women with
with so much independence and knowing
where they're going well I I appreciate
that because I guess I just missed them
but many of them are our faculty if you
look at the especially the engineering
school you look where they come from we
have quite a few of our own let me go
back to a Sheila for a minute I was on I
was the first woman to be on the
athletic committee and it was a time
when we were just trying to get
facilities so it was available and get
what do you call them intramurals moved
into into the what do you call the the
women in yeah well we were trying to get
them and into some other two into teams
that can be competitive with other
schools and so forth it was a really
difficult task at the time but I was on
the committee and was able to we had
some supportive faculty members on the
committee but there was a time when that
wasn't working very well and they the
woman they hired as the athletic
director was just terrific as far as
being an entrepreneur and getting women
excited and on to the two programs and
so forth but she had crossed some of the
male staff members over there and so it
looked like she was going to leave in
any case I couldn't take on the on the
job because I was on the committee and
it would look like I was playing too so
I asked Sheila if she would look at that
well it's all she needed you know she
jumped she just jumped right in and got
a group together of students who were
participating in all the different
sports
and we came up with another report which
I can't give you the date but it
certainly is worth reviewing that 1977
was it yeah I know it was that would be
about the time yeah that's right that's
right we had it in the 1972 report where
people stone and the co-chairman we had
a section on athletics but that was sort
of precede it that's right that was in
title nine that's right we did we never
really struggled with title nine I think
I think we've always been able to yes we
were always ahead and often so but but
the sports programs weren't equal in the
sense that that some of the students
felt that we weren't teaching those
courses as well as we could have but but
Sheila's report I think settled it it's
never been an issue since I mean she
addressed all the right issues she got
all the right people to jump in and to
and we met several times I remember and
that was a model report and it was an
excellent report bunch of each of them
had an impact amazing you know I after
that when I started doing things for the
federal government you know in our
national research council and so forth I
thought that all the reports should have
equal impact it was hard to beat these
that's right very slowly we're so very
yeah I really learned a lot from this
and I think would you know would be a
model report for today that kind of that
kind of but it's into intercollegiate
sports that I was trying to to get at
because there was a lack of of other
teams to play because we weren't in the
various sports programs and we needed
someone to get us into them and the
woman who was here at the time was not
in that kind of position so we did hire
them Jane Betts who came and and I think
just recently left but was just great I
mean she just knew her way around the
sports world which none of us did but
Sheila was really the person who
made that goal made that work and she
also made work on better facilities and
locker rooms and yes and I know we have
I remember even the principle equal to
ish in equal she missed she had heard
she had a daughter a man one day we were
out of meeting and we were really making
good progress and everything was coming
together and she looked at her watch and
she said I've just missed an who was her
daughter's soccer game and I have to get
out of here to go see that so we knew
she was encouraging and to participate
in soccer good reports have been written
here but but they didn't go to just a
sort of faceless bureaucracy there were
people up there that were reading the
report they cared about I'm listening
and and if it hadn't been a good report
probably nothing would have happened but
you do need we had our first bad report
back in 1972 or something when Jerry
Wiesner taught us how to do we do learn
from your perspective now which is we
have to raise a unique perspective
collectively here what does the next 50
years mean or women at MIT good things
probably and struggled but I don't
challenge but that's life and that's the
whole it all educational institutions
are up against real challenges and so
are the students who go to them and the
faculty teachers and the faculty every
you know it's real it's a very very very
important cause and it's got to stay
high quality but it's hard to predict
how it's gonna turn out but I have my
faith that you know people that work
hard and have good brains something will
come of it I still work with a women's
independent living group as an advisor
and now I'm very I'm always very
impressed when I
they're how how much in stride they take
things that maybe some years ago we're
not taking in stride I think these
things are they deal with things and
they are don't feel that they have to
run for help for everything they feel
they can deal with it as a group then
very good and they're very capable of
managing their own affairs and taking
their expectations are similar to the
men yes yes yes and I think the fact
that there are alumni of that group that
they invite back every year and I just
went to their to their banquet which was
very impressive people who said you know
how much they loved being at MIT how
much it had meant to them and their
careers and living there had been it's a
it's a it's a real tribute to to what's
happened here I think that was that's a
good message
I guess one challenge is to get the
faculty and graduate students more in
sync with the undergraduate experience
here because there still is a disparity
just in sheer numbers and yeah but the
critical mass is a very different
critical mess in each of those layers
that will come with time yes
well and it would I believe we have to
look and see where the graduate students
are coming from within our own place so
we're 40 some percent women right for
the undergraduates your numbers better
than I do but in the we only accept a
small number of our own students in the
graduate program and when you look
around the rest of the the country or
the world the percentage of women in
these various fields that we specialize
in here is a smaller number than her own
undergraduate population so we could
expect we cannot not expect that the
numbers would be the same right so we'll
have to wait a while for that's that -
that's for 15 years you have a
difference Yeah right and likewise for
faculty ranks I think it's it's the same
thing and we should just can continue to
advocate some measure of affirmative
action
we have and it seems to work because we
have enough women out there that when
they come they participate in the
mainstream and by and large they do just
as well as the men do matter of time
it's not easy being a faculty member
here the male bands are great yeah oh
yes and if it's not this has nothing to
do with the Institute and regulations
the the pace here is intense and it's
hard to do combined family life and and
try to have international career right
it's really hard to do that and and and
the problem is that it all hits you with
the same age group 20 to 30 25 to 35 is
the critical time for all of us and we
don't have the answer to that one and
it's not an MIT problem mimosa
we're so intense here yeah makes it more
difficult